merci annie je voudrais te remercier
pour le travail que tu as accompli dans
le cadre de la préparation de cette
convention sur l'autorité de notre état
général eric woerth pourrait saluer mes
amis parlementaires tous ceux qui sont
ici présents et chers amis en préparant
cette convention nous avons essayé de
nous poser un certain nombre de
questions
c'est pas facile parce que quand on
vient sur le lieu de ses crimes et qu'il
faut prendre un peu de champ de recul
pensez l'avenir il faut essayer de
mettre en oeuvre l'exercice de la page
blanche finalement et je me disais
meilleur moyen de réfléchir à l'avenir
de l'école c'est de repartir finalement
de ses missions la mission essentielle a
beaucoup disserté sur les missions de
l'école
on a toujours voulu considérer que
l'école était responsable de tous
devaient s'occuper tout moi je me
souviens d'une anecdote quand vous êtes
mise l'éducation nationale
il ya deux caractéristiques d'abord
c'est que tout le monde a un avis sur
tout c'est un peu comme sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france de football les 65
millions de ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui vous explique ce qu'il
faut faire
et la deuxième chose c'est que à la
table du conseil des ministres
chaque mercredi vous avez un collègue
qui vient voir les il faudrait
absolument qu'on se voie parce qu' il
faudrait qu'on parle de la sécurité
routière à l'école personnes d'après
c'est il faudrait qu'on parle de
l'environnement à l'école à il faudrait
qu'on parle de la formation là la sûreté
je pas koala l'école à il faudrait qu'on
parle x et y ait en fait tout le monde
voudrait qu'on parle de tous les sujets
à l'école et ça ça finit par quoi ça
finit par le fait qu'on en oublie nos
fondamentaux
voilà il ya trois missions pour l'école
de la république
nous en avions parlé souvent ensemble
mon certaines by instruire premièrement
instruire transmettre le savoir
deuxièmement éduquer parce qu'il ya des
choses qui malheureusement ça prenne pas
forcément dans la famille dans
l'environnement personnel et qu'ils
doivent s'apprendre à l'école puis enfin
un troisième objectif que la gauche a
toujours négligé que la droite nous
n'avons pas suffisamment assumé pendant
des années c'est l'insertion
professionnelle l'école c'est très bien
mais l'école c'est pour faire quoi ça
débouche sur quoi ça débouche sur
l'insertion dans la vie tout court ça
qu'elle doit vous donner les armes et
bagages pour être un citoyen éclairé et
heureux c'est ça le sujet instruire
éduquer insérer professionnellement
instruire ça veut dire et moi je
rebondis sur les propositions dali et de
son équipe
ça veut dire que beaucoup moi c'est
beaucoup appris de ces questions pendant
mon séjour grenelle c'est d'abord aux
primaires que tout se passe je dire aux
primaires hap à la primaire ont pas tout
me tout mélanger un succès c'est à la
mode un bon donc c'est aux primaires que
tout se passe et donc vous verrez les
mesures que nous proposons en faveur de
l'apprentissage des fondamentaux
moi j'avais été frappé par un chiffre 16
% d'une classe d'âge 16 % passent en
sixième en ne maîtrisant pas la lecture
16%
vous faites la même statistique six ans
plus tard oui huit ans plus tard au
moment de ce qui n'existe plus et elle
est trois jours maintenant c'est la
journée d'appel de la défense qui a
encore changé de nom plus comment il
s'appelle bref on fait sur toute une
classe d'âge à 18 ans des tests
d'évaluation sur la lecture
eh bien ils sont 16% à 18 ans à ne pas
maîtriser la lecture
voilà donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que ce qui n'a pas été possible en
terme d'apprentissage d'acquisition d'un
manteau aux primaires ça n'a pas été
corrigée par le collège et par le lycée
ça veut bien dire que c'est d'abord à
l'école primaire et qu'il faut mettre le
paquet sur l'apprentissage des
fondamentaux et nous avons je trouve des
propositions innovantes en la matière
sur notamment le cp et l'apprentissage
de la lecture
deuxième chose tout à l'heure frédéric
frédéric reiss qui est un de nos grands
spécialistes de l'éducation nationale
à l'assemblée nationale et je veux le
remercier parce que il a énormément
accompagner la majorité de l'époque qui
continue à beaucoup travailler pour
défendre nos valeurs nos idées notre
vision de l'école et bien frédéric parlé
tout à l'heure de la personnalisation
si vous voulez améliorer l'instruction
si vous voulez élever le niveau
quel est l'enjeu d'aujourd'hui l'enjeu
c'est d'être capable de s'adapter à
chaque enfant
j'appartiens à une génération j'ai passé
mon bac ya quelques années nous étions
20 % d'une classe d'âge a accédé au
baccalauréat 20 pose aujourd'hui 70% et
l'objectif toujours afficher encore
c'est 80 %
qu'est ce qui a changé pas ce qui a
changé c'est la divine par sous le
contrôle des enseignants qui sont dans
la salle c'est la diversité des
situations
c'est pas pareil de faire la classe à
une classe entre guillemets homogène et
à une classe où vous avez la diversité
de la population française ou vos
missions ne doivent pas être de niveler
par le bas mais doit d'aller chercher
les cinq dans la classe qui ont un
talent fou qu'on va tirer vers le haut
et qu'on va n'ayons pas peur du mot
poussé vers l'excellence parce que
l'excellence de l'école ça doit être un
objectif pour nous l'excellence
républicaine et en même temps tenir
compte des 12 ou 14 qui dans la classe
sont vaguement en train de décrocher et
vont avoir besoin d'un accompagnement
spécifique pour éviter qu'ils fassent
partie des 150 milles qui quittent le
système sans rien donc ça ça passe par
des pédagogies par des changements
majeurs dans la mission le contenu de la
mission des enseignants et le drame
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les enseignants
travaillent trop avec les méthodes ya 25
ans alors que le contenu de la classe et
la sociologie de la classe a changé donc
instruire et éduquer oui parce que
l'école c'est à l'école qu'on apprend
règle oui nous assumons des valeurs de
la droite du centre
nous devons nous avons trop oublié une
génération a oublié que l'élève n'était
pas légale du maître et qu' il fallait
replacer le savoir l'enseignant la règle
au coeur de notre système éducatif
regardez il a fallu qu'on ait des
attentats de l'année dernière pour qu'on
replace quelque part la mission en
matière de de transmission des valeurs
de la république au coeur des missions
de l'école donc l'éducation
c'est cela l'éducation à la règle le
respect de la règle respect de
l'enseignant nous avions créé je sais
que nicolas sarkozy vous en parlera tout
à l'heure en 2010 ou 2009
mon cher mon cher frédéric les
établissements de réinsertion scolaire
c'était quoi cette idée c'était cette
idée que les élèves dont plus personne
ne veut et où les établissements
solaires fils parce que la meilleure des
sanctions c'est l exclusion excusez moi
vers des sanctions de l'exclusion ça
aboutit à quoi ça aboutit à la
déscolarisation ça aboutit excusez moi
au bout à la délinquance
or system bon eh bien nous avions
réfléchi ces élèves là qui sont des
turbulents qui perturbe la classe donc
pour lesquels il faut un traitement
spécifique
eh bien on va créer des établissements
très particulier qui vont les accueillir
pendant une durée déterminée avec pour
objectif de les réinsérer dans le
système éducatif classique c'était les
fameuses établissement d'un sociologue
nous vous proposerons de d'investir
massivement dans ce type de
d'établissements de réinsertion scolaire
et puis enfin l'insertion
professionnelle écoutez nous vîmes
marchons sur la tête avec un système où
dans nos régions moi je le vois dans ma
région qui est très rurale mais en même
temps industrielle où nous avons des
besoins
si d'érable dans des métiers dans la
forge fonderie la coutellerie la
plasturgie et nous n'avons pas soit les
formations adaptées parce que la carte
des formations et inadapté elle est
inadaptée aux besoins
demain de mêlée aussi inadaptées entre
les lycées professionnels et les cfa et
puis de l'autre on a des corps de jeunes
qu'on envoie en socio psycho en staps et
qui déboucheront sur rien voilà donc
nous devrons remettre le paquet à mon
sens sur un système d'orientation qui
doit être beaucoup plus progressif qui
doit être réversible qui doit intégrer
les chèques se tromper ça doit être une
chance dans la vie
une chance de rebondir de redémarrer
alors qu'en france on a la dictature de
l'échec
il a échoué il a redoublé terrible donc
nous devons devront beaucoup travailler
sur cela
nous les socialistes ont fait une énorme
bêtise je pense à notre ami gérard
cherpion
ça a été de supprimer l'apprentissage à
14 ans nous devrons réinstaurer
l'apprentissage à 14 ans nous devrons
mieux coordonner lycée professionnel et
cfa parce qu'on voit bien aujourd'hui
que le système ne fonctionne pas donc on
doit avoir une prise de conscience qui
doit être cette insertion
professionnelle que la france ne réussit
pas au regard de ses voisins européens
évidemment je pense à nos amis allemands
alors pour mettre tout ça en mouvement
pour revenir à ces trois missions
fondamentales
ça passe c'est vrai par une vision de
l'organisation du système éducatif qui
doit être profondément moderne qu'est ce
que c'est un système éducatif moderne
c'est un système qui comprend ce que
c'est que la responsabilité
là j'ai mis deux ans à travailler et à
finir par signer un peu tard c'était
entre les deux tours des élections
présidentielles mais un travail de deux
ans un décret sur l'évaluation des
enseignants écoutez nous marchons sur la
tête
aujourd'hui nous avons un système où les
enseignants sont évalués en moyenne une
fois tous les sept ans sur des critères
qui ne couvre qu'une partie infime de
leur mission et on oublie
des pans entiers de ce que doivent être
la mission aujourd'hui des enseignants
il nous faut repenser le contenu de la
mission des enseignants et je vous dit
tout à l'heure on n'a pas changé de
logiciel
alors que dans la classe ça a changé
certes la transmission du savoir
l'instruction le court c'est la base du
métier
mais le soutien scolaire l'animation du
projet pédagogique d'établissement la
présence dans l'établissement
le travail avec les familles avec les
parents je n'ai pas peur du mot comme
par exemple l'enseignement privé sous
contrat
c'est beaucoup mieux le faire parfois
que le système public
eh bien ça ça passe par une révision de
ce que sont les missions des enseignants
est donc un travail sur le temps de
présence sur le temps de service des
enseignants
ça me semble essentiel nous aurons
besoin et il faut que nous assumions de
moins d'enseignants mieux formés mieux
préparer mieux sélectionner mieux
rémunérer mieux au total évalué avec des
perspectives d'évolution
c'est ça l'enjeu alors que moi je me
souviens les discussions sur par exemple
dans une réforme du lycée le nombre
d'heures de cours d'histoire de sciences
de france est finalement la seule grille
de lecture
c'était une heure de cours égal tant de
poste supplémentaire d'enseignant c'est
ça la logique des syndicats aujourd'hui
c'est absurde
alors que nous nous savons que nous
avons besoin d'enseignants qui doivent
être mieux formés nous devons faire
amende honorable
nous avons voulu et nous avions raison
nous avions raison la mastérisation
c'est à dire former les enseignants à
l'université parce que six universités
françaises elles forment pas les
enseignants c'est quand même le plus
beau message qu'on puisse envoyer
l'université française de dire c'est
elle qui a en charge la formation de
ceux qui vont transmettre le savoir mais
en même temps nous n'avons pas
suffisamment travaillé sur la formation
pratique et bien nous devrons reprendre
l'initiative
je sais que ça fait partie de thé
proposition
annie et ça c'est très important pour
l'avenir pour la formation de nos
enseignants puis enfin vous l'avez
évoqué dans la table ronde la
responsabilité l'organisation du système
ça veut dire des chefs d'établissement
qui soient de véritables patrons oui
nous sommes des gens de droite
donc nous considérons qu'il faut de
l'autorité il pour qu'un système
organisé fonctionne il faut un patron
pour un responsable et bien qui mieux
que le chef d'établissement peut exercer
cette mission
moi j'avais mis en place à titre
expérimental dans 300 collèges
difficiles
un système qui prévoyait de nommer une
autonomie totale aux chefs
d'établissement c'est à dire qu'il soit
capable de recruter ses équipes sur la
base d'un projet que les enseignants
soient volontaires parce qu'ils allaient
dans un établissement difficile qui soit
mieux rémunéré qu'il soit évalué par le
chef d'établissement et qu'à la fin on
c'est à dire vous - des familles
puissent évaluer l'ensemble du
dispositif
écoutez nous sommes dans un système où
quoi qu'on fasse dans la vie on va à
l'hôtel on évalue son hôtel on prend un
taxi un über en évalue son taxi et on
évaluerait pas le système éducatif
enfin les français ils doivent être
capables on doit leur donner la capacité
d'évaluer le système éducatif
voilà donc nous avons beaucoup en
préparant ce séminaire beaucoup
travaillé beaucoup planché pour
réfléchir à un système adapté au monde
d'aujourd'hui
ce 21ème siècle qui est celui du savoir
qui est celui de l'économie de la
connaissance
eh bien les républicains ils doivent
incarner cette ce nouveau monde du
savoir
ce nouveau monde de la connaissance mais
pour cela ça passera par des réformes
profondes de l'organisation et je
termine en lui disant vous savez la
bonne nouvelle
évidemment le bon souvenir en hangar de
la rue de grenelle
on en sort vivant il est au bout de
trois ans tout va bien je garde le
souvenir peut-être le plus important est
le message d'espoir que je voudrais
porter particulier à ceux qui aurait
l'ambition d'occuper ce grand et beau
ministère
on peut réformer l'éducation nationale
c'est possible simplement pour le faire
si vous arrivez vous êtes le 20 heures
de tf1 et vous dit écoutez
amis vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir on va réformer l'éducation
nationale et enfin on va vous mettre au
boulot
il ya peu de chances que ça marche donc
il faut on peut réformer l'éducation
nationale à condition d'avoir une vision
d'avoir un projet adapté au monde
d'aujourd'hui
et comme dans les grandes organisations
comme dans les entreprises faire adhérer
celles et ceux qui en sont les
principaux acteurs à cette grande
mission à ce grand projet c'est
aujourd'hui la la vision que j'ai en
tête et je tenais à vous la faire
partager au début de ce séminaire
merci à vous